down in Florida Ron DeSantis just
showing the model for what conservative
Governors and frankly what what
conservatives at the federal level
should be doing Ron DeSantis
has just threatened to stop Chinese
Communists from buying real estate in
the United States
High View on the our economy is in
Florida is you know we don't want to
have Holdings by hostile Nations and so
if you look at the Chinese Communist
Party they've been very active
throughout the Western hemisphere in
gobbling up land and investing in
different things and you know when when
they have interests that are opposed to
ours and you see how they've wielded
their Authority and especially with
President XI who's taken a a much more
Marxist leninist turn since he's been
ruling China that is not in the best
interest of Florida to have the Chinese
Communist Party owning Farmland owning
land close to military bases but you
know my view is and I think there's a
broad agreement in those two but my view
is okay yeah no Farmland but why would
you want them buying residential
developments or things like that I don't
want them owning subdivisions and things
like that I think that the the issue is
just going to be I think people agree
with that the issue is going to be yeah
obviously if someone comes in and buys
it's not the CCP that's signing that
these are holding companies and all that
so you got to structure that in a way
that will effectively police it but yes
we do not need to have CCP influence in
Florida's economy
yes yes oh I just love it I wish I had a
a sort of New Year's Eve blowhorn an
American flag to wave around listening
to that clip this is so beautiful Rhonda
santis totally gets it here and I really
hope this policy goes into effect
because it is going to not only is it
morally and politically astute and right
but it's going to irritate all the right
people
because the limbs are going to go crazy
what do you mean you're taking away our
Chinese Communist influence in America
you can't do that
but it's also going to irritate the
squishes
it's going to irritate the squishes
because the squishes are going to say
well
yeah sure I don't I mean I don't want
the Chinese Communists having political
control over America but
you know what about the free market
what about aren't we supposed to allow
anybody to buy anything that he wants
we're not talking about the Chinese
Communists putting a spy into the
Pentagon now we're just talking about
them buying up some land
so now now the heavy hand of the
centralized government you statists
you run DeSantis you big government
concern you're going to go in and tell
people what they can buy in the free
market yes
and and you know they might even be able
to rationalize themselves okay well
maybe you can put certain limits on how
we operate in the free market if we're
talking about
a political party or a foreign power so
okay maybe I don't know if I love this
because I hate tariffs and I hate all
restrictions on free trade and but all
right uh maybe the CCP cannot buy land
in America okay fine I'm willing to go
there but then Ron DeSantis points out
he says
do you think the Chinese Communists are
are coming in they're going up to
Houlihan Lawrence real estate and
they're saying okay uh yes uh where do I
put chairman xi's signature on the
dotted line you think she is flying over
to him he's saying okay here's the CCP
credit card I want to buy this on behalf
of the Communist party no of course not
the way that the Chinese are buying
land in America and amassing even more
political power than they already have
is through intermediaries through
holding companies through individuals
who are connected to the Communist party
and so DeSantis is saying if we're
actually going to do anything about this
we gotta we gotta put it into effect in
a way that that will be practical
and and he points out actually later in
those comments he says we've already
done this at the universities we've gone
after the Confucius institutes Confucius
institutes are they're not the Chinese
Communist party club
they they have a facade of being purely
academic or purely cultural or not
related but what DeSantis and other GOP
politicians Ted Cruz in particular have
pointed out is no they're just fronts
for the Communist party they should be
banned from the universities let's go
baby wield the heavy hand of the state
to protect our national security
interests
but but just to protect our country it
if we're living in a country right now
and and depending on where you live in
the United States you might be seeing
this directly if we're living in a
country where a hostile foreign power is
coming in and buying up a lot of real
estate that doesn't only present a
national security interest that presents
economic hardship and an upending of the
political order
simply by the fact that they're driving
up real estate prices you got a ton of
money coming out of China coming into
the United States from the party
that is driving up your rent driving up
your mortgage
you see the Santa series saying yeah of
course with the Farmland that that
presents an immediate security threat
but he says why do we want the Chinese
Communists buying residential property
either
it's a reminder and DeSantis gets this
and he's not the only Republican to get
this but he has articulated it in a in a
really powerful way in a really clear
way he understands that
the economy is for the nation
the nation is not for the economy
free market principles
open trade those those can be good
things
but they are a means to an end and the
end is a good country and a flourishing
society and when we put the cart before
the horse then things get a little bit
wonky Rhonda Santos is not a stalinist
okay he's not some heavy-handed big
authoritarian government he's a normal
politician who recognizes that we live
in a republic and Republic comes from
race public that means public things and
he understands that his job is to govern
for the common good of all that's why
states are instituted and that that
doesn't mean confiscating property and
turning us all into commies quite the
opposite he's saying we need to reduce
the power of the Communists and the way
to do that is to wield just political
power that the people have given us
through our form of government really
really great stuff I hope that other
conservatives take note the libs have
dispirited us for so so long they've
made us think well you can you guys can
never wield political power well
DeSantis is showing we can other GOP
politicians are too but DeSantis is
doing it in a really really clear way my
producer Ben Davies has a story every
week that he's upset that I don't get to
and so I've got the story here facing
upside down I will flip it over and read
the story for the first time you got to
go to the member block to do that okay
that is dailywire.com Knowles use code
nulls at checkout you will get two
months free on all annual plans see at
the member block
[Music]
[Music]